lors de son dernier voyage aux etats
unis le pape avait été contraint
d'évoquer publiquement ses affaires
délicates je veux parler des milliers
d'américains accusant des prêtres d'abus
sexuels des scandales qui font grand
bruit aux états unis où l'église préfère
le plus souvent payer de fortes
indemnités afin d'éviter des procès
gênant reportage de notre correspondant
permanent bruno albin
âme hornsby à 61 ans elle se souvient de
monseigneur mccluskey comme de l'évêque
qui fit bâtir cette église mais surtout
comme de l'homme qui détruisit son
existence en abusant d'elle sexuellement
elle n'avait que 4 ans le secret de
presque toute une vie
il y a 6 ans je suis allé voir des
prêtres je leur ai tout raconté l'un
d'eux a dit à une de mes amies que
j'étais folle que rien de tout cela
n'était vrai
c'était dans la banlieue de philadelphie
dans des familles très croyante comme
celle de steve et john ils n'ont
aujourd'hui qu'une trentaine d'années
mais ont vécu le même désastre une
enfance ravagée par des prêtres
pédophiles des souvenirs saccagé 7 à 8
ans sous le toit même de ses parents que
steve a subi les premières étreintes de
l'homme qui l'a maintenu sous son empire
pendant près de vingt ans
il me faisait vivre dans un monde
complètement imaginaire il me répétait
sans cesse que dieu comprenez mais c'est
blesse et les pardonner
l'histoire de john est presque la même à
18 ans pour fuir en silence il s'est
engagé les marines dont chassé pour
mauvaise conduite
aujourd'hui les prêtres ne tirent plus
les ficelles de ma vie je n'ai plus peur
vis de l'église ni deux ils font partie
d'un groupe de 15 personnes auxquelles
le diocèse a versé en octobre dernier un
total de plus de 10 millions de francs
de dommages et intérêts sans y être
contraint par la justice mais en échange
de leur silence mais ils parlent comme
des milliers d'américains aujourd'hui
organisé qui dénonce des sévices sexuels
que des prêtres leur ont imposé il ya
parfois des années sur ce film amateur
le père james porter aujourd'hui
défroqué mais accusée par près de 200
personnes 68 affaire aurait fait l'objet
d'un règlement à l'amiable pour un
montant de 30 millions de francs
cet homme fuyant les caméras de
télévision l'été dernier c'est james
portèrent marié père de quatre enfants
finalement condamné à 16 ans de prison
le mois dernier à chicago les 2 millions
300 mille catholiques du diocèse ont
serré les rangs autour de leurs cardinal
monseigneur bernardin lorsqu'il a été à
son tour accusé d'abus sexuels par un
ancien séminariste en novembre dernier
mais trop de scandales ont éclaté dans
trop de paroisses du même diocèse et
pour ce prêtre qui dit avoir choisi de
regarder la vérité en face il ne faut
pas entretenir le doute
il ya sans doute des milliers de
victimes dans ce diocèse sûrement si
l'on considère que ses hommes ont tous
molesté une centaine de personnes tout
au long de leur carrière
leurs histoires qu'il raconte avec
dégoût semble incroyable a beaucoup de
ceux qui l'écoutent mais ils veulent
continuer à la dire
nous ne faisons pas ça pour l'argent ni
pour la publicité mais pour aider les
autres vous avez vu ce garçon là c'est
moi quand j'étais violentée par les
prêtres et on devrait les considérer
comme dieu dieu lui-même ne le
supporterait pas